who are your top quarterbacks in the  conference what some of the guys that  you admire yeah no order at all for sure  but my homes of course even though I  can't stand over cheese being in Denver  and stuff like that got to give credit  with credit do so for show my home  Herbert I used to tell him all the time  man you're one of my favorite young  quarterbacks bro like every time we  played him no matter if I hit him or not  I'll tell them maybe you got it bro just  keep going who else who else two of  course Joe burrow I feel like Trevor  Lawrence coming on real strong these  past couple games man it's good to see  him like living up and like doing what  he do or Josh Alabama